foreign
hi this is Jenny from Columbus Missouri
I'm wondering how you would respond to a
friend or family member who tries to
sell you on an item that you've told
them that you don't need for instance my
home does actually have plenty of extra
storage space I just see no reason to
fill it with unwanted items so often
when I tell a family member I don't need
something they'll come back and say
something along the lines of but you
have plenty of available storage space
maybe you'll need this in the future
my no thank you ends up feeling like a
broken record this family member usually
ends up responding in a hurtful way or
making it seem like I'm grateful for not
wanting their cast off
how should I deal with this situation
I've tried everything hmm
so we were talking about this earlier
Ryan but as soon as you need something
it begins to control you if you need the
approval of your friends and family if
you need the people in your life
to have the same preferences or ideas
around their material possessions then
you will need to conform to their ideas
and ideology of what is appropriate and
what you're realizing the tension that
you're expressing in your life right now
is oh I'm not completely compatible with
the people in my life and that's okay my
preferences aren't their preferences but
as soon as you realize that you realize
that their reaction is also an emotional
reaction because they're reacting in
judgment what is Judgment judgment
simply means I don't like something the
way that it is it is the opposite of
accepting and what you're telling me
Grace is your friends are having trouble
accepting you for who you are and so
your friends in a way are having trouble
loving you now we often think love is
well we think codependency is love we
think trauma bonding is love so trauma
bonding basically means we both have
shared traumas or I have some sort of
trauma in my life and I'm going to get
someone to fulfill that whole that void
that is in my own life to try to
compensate for my own trauma well
recognizing having compassion for the
people around you recognizing I'm not
the only one with the trauma they also
have trauma and maybe one of the ways
they deal with that trauma is but
they're trying to contribute to you
Jenny they're trying to say hey I want
you to have this not realizing what is
triggering them to force their rightness
their things their judgment onto you
because what's happening now is your
friends are inadvertently
and your family or inadvertently placing
themselves on a pedestal because they're
saying I have the right idea of what
would work for you
and what you're simply saying is no that
doesn't work for me I'm not saying it's
a bad thing I'm not saying you shouldn't
have it I'm not saying it doesn't work
for you either I'm simply saying that
doesn't work for me I'd like to present
a fairly hysterical or hyperbolic
example around this if you had a family
member who walked up to your house and
they gave you a bag of dog poop
and I said you have plenty of room for
this
[Laughter]
here Ryan you take care of this
Not only would you say no
because no is a complete sentence Jenny
no no no
you would say hell no to it why because
it's going to stink up my house well
it's easy for you to understand that the
dog poop is going to stink up your house
but these other things are going to
stink up your life in various ways
clutter is going to stink up your life
excess material possessions will stink
up your life but also your family and
friends expectations if you need to
conform to them they control you and
that control will also stink up your
life and so how do you regain control
you simply say no and when no doesn't
work you find another way to say no but
it's important that if you've identified
a boundary
then sticking to that boundary is the
only way the boundary stays a boundary
I'm just imagining like her family
member giving her something and she's
like you might as well have handed me a
bag of dog poop
I would not recommend saying that Jenny
oh a couple things you know
um Jenny anytime I have to say no to
something that I'm uncomfortable saying
no to meaning that I'm scared I'm gonna
hurt someone else's feelings
I try to be as compassionate as possible
you know if you're if you're if your no
comes from a place of how dare you like
that's going to come out if that's your
context then that's going to come out
and it is going to create some tension
but if your no is coming from a place of
man I really appreciate you looking out
for me but
um that's just not something that I
needed in my life but thank you so much
for trying to contribute to me which is
exactly what they're trying to do like
you've got family friends whatever
trying to give you things because they
want to make your life better in some
way
so for me if I had a persistent family
member trying to always give me things I
would go out of my way
to
I don't know show them how I see them
showing up in my life and supporting me
because it's really what that family
member wants to do and you know we talk
about The Love Languages and gift gift
giving is like one of these Love
Languages and we've talked you know
plenty about how that's probably not
true uh it's more of the contribution
aspect of it but this is this person
trying to show you their love by giving
you a gift and maybe they're not doing
it in a way that you prefer
um that's okay just show them how you do
receive their love in in various ways
and uh I don't know that makes that
makes the know a lot easier but coming
from a place of compassion and and like
seeing that person respecting that
person
um really showing that person that you
understand them that that is how you can
deliver uncomfortable news uh to someone
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free